well berea two and two again that last
start thursday at baltimore he was
unable to finish the fourth ended up
allowing only one earned run on five
hits but it was a game that got away
from the angels in the middle innings
and they were stuck with a 13-1 loss in
baltimore that day and now it's anthony
rizzo they do send the runner and rizzo
bounces it to fletch for the first down
of the night still a full count to
stanton
with a lot of back spin on it
relay to first he's in time to double
him off wow didn't think that was hit
hard enough to turn the double play but
well executed by the angels that angel
lineup going to face the right-hander
jameson taion his
start 8-4 4.18 era we'll look at our
pitchers scouting report on tyone he's
coming off a red rare bad start only
three and two-thirds five runs and no
decision against the oakland days and he
got himself in a little bit of trouble
with his fastball opponents three for
ten so here's david fletcher
popped up on the right side lemay
one down the bat path is beautiful the
front foot is down early
high fly ball left field not deep
gala puts it away for the second out the
crowd is the majority of yankee fans
it's uh it's leaning yankees let's put
it that way swing and a miss struck him
out swinging fast while on the outside
edge so the angels go down one two three
there's walsh to lead off the bottom of
the second good life early in this one
for tyonne
there's life right there as walsh
strikes out one away that's a nice job
recognizing it too if you're gary
sanchez and ty owen you got something
special at the top of the zone 34.95 a
little bit of hop on it you take
advantage of that early on
adele's at 226. swing and a miss
certainly went around there third
strikeout in a row for tyonne i love it
this is good old-fashioned hardball
right here i got a good heater and i'm
gonna come right at you i don't think
you can hit my fastball i don't think
you can hit it when i can elevate it
three consecutive strikeouts all of them
on the elevated fastball that brings up
brandon marsh
0-2 cutout in this he struck out the
side that was 94. nothing nothing is
we go to the fourth inning rizzo 2-1
deep to right field going back is
lagarus on the track he leaps he can't
make the play oh he says it's a home run
it went over the yellow line so it is
gone
as the umpire signals that it went over
the yellow line rizzo with
the yankees with a one-nothing lead so
obviously the ground rule has changed
out in anaheim because it always used to
be that it had to find the seats over
that tall right wall and right field
yeah they've made the uh the wall now
the yellow line so hit him on top of the
wall over the yellow line well you think
about lagarres who was kind of drifting
drifting and he's right up against the
wall
he could have made that play
we'll see what they say in new york
it's a home run
again lagaris right up against the wall
hits above that yellow line and comes
back into the field of play but ruled a
home run so back to jared walsh now he
was a strikeout victim in his first try
still runners at first and second one
gone still and two to walsh
cover
breaking balls
lines that one out
three run home run another big home run
against the yankees
for walsh
remember in new york two home runs
including a grand slam here a three run
home run
huge swing looking to make contact he
hits it on the line and gets it
boy does he stay back on breaker balls
from right-handed pitchers doesn't
matter how quickly he was going to get
out three-run homer
and the angel's first lead of the night
gary lined out to second his first time
the 1-1 that one has drilled deep to
left field
there it goes see ya a long home run
into the bleachers in anaheim sanchez
goes yard and it's 3-2 angels
well when you watch gary sanchez
eliminating that big leg kick his swings
have been so much cleaner lately you're
just waiting for him to get hot that's a
fastball right down the middle great
extension home run number 18.
no doubt about that one with the bat
flip
see if we can take a look at this again
and a big breaking pitch but it stayed
about thigh high he just missed with
that spot gary knew immediately oh the
minute he swung the bat and here's
goslin looking to cash in with two away
stassi mayfield and ohtani aboard
it's a fast run
for a base hit he's gonna score at least
two
phil gosling comes
the goose can cover a fastball
good at that work through a 2-2 count
aaron boone gonna make the change now
after that swing by phil gosling well he
was ready and he was ready to drive a
fastball
but jameson taion was a strike away from
getting out of an inning that started
with runners at second and third and
nobody out instead phil gosselin cashes
in back to a three-run lead
and walsh will be the first to face the
new yankee pitcher
left-hander joely rodriguez takes over
for jamison tyonne
a swing and a miss a delayed double
steal it's him
[Applause]
if it stands it's the second stolen base
of the game for shohei
gosselin draws the throw and then shohei
was off to the races that was a delayed
steal to draw that throw and gets a hand
in just before the tag that's so close
just before the tag they're not going to
challenge it either
three builders on the left side infield
is back they'll give up a run they're up
by
four punched out base hit to right field
lemayo scores rizzo advances the third
it's an rbi single for judge and it's
six three angels
again talked about it earlier in the
game how aaron judge is letting the
baseball travel so deep he'll get a
great look from the side here
and just stays inside the baseball and
blocks it the other way
be another base hit another rbi and the
yankees one run
closer and here's stanton one swing away
from tying the game first and third
nobody out
did he tie the game deep to left field
going back to dally's on the track and
he makes the play
tagging his rizzo he'll score easily
judge goes back to first and stanton
just missed it but picks up the sac fly
and the yankees close to within two and
now he's one out away from saving an
angels
gets a swing a ground ball for gosselin
long throw good night
the angels with a 6-4 victory tonight
you